Queridos amigos, en VisualPolitik nos hemos dado
cuenta de un fallo bastante grave. Llevamos más
de 7 años lanzando vídeos todas las semanas sobre
los lugares y temas más variopintos. Sin embargo,
en todos estos años nos hemos olvidado
del vecino ibérico de España: Portugal.
Pero eso se acaba hoy.
Conocido por sus famosos navegantes
y exploradores, como Vasco de Gama o
Fernando de Magallanes, Portugal llegó a ser,
hace siglos, el mayor imperio de toda Europa.
Lo fue hasta que la corona de Castilla alcanzó
América. Hoy, sin embargo, se encuentra entre
los países más rezagados de Europa Occidental.
De hecho, esta es una circunstancia que comparte
con sus hermanos mediterráneos, España y Grecia.
Y desde luego tampoco es algo nuevo. La historia
de Portugal es una plagada de
inestabilidad y muchas crisis.
Sin ir más lejos, hace poco acabamos de
conocer la dimisión de su primer ministro
que está siendo investigado por corrupción.
C3 (“La dignidad de las tareas de un primer
ministro no son compatibles con ninguna sospecha
sobre la integridad, el buen comportamiento y
menos aún con cualquier tipo de acto delictivo”.
Antonio Costa, exprimer ministro de Portugal)
De hecho, como veréis, últimamente, las dimisiones
en este país con casi un deporte nacional.
Claro que no todo es malo. ¿Sabéis
qué nos enseña también su historia,
sobre todo la más reciente? Que con trabajo
duro se puede salir de cualquier atolladero.
De hecho, Portugal se ha convertido para muchos
en un claro modelo a seguir para hacer frente
a nuevas crisis. Podríamos, incluso, decir
que la terrible crisis financiera del 2008
que agitó todo el mundo puso por fin
las pilas a una aletargada Portugal.
Claro que en el último año también
hemos podido ver noticias como esta:
N1(Miles de personas se manifiestan
contra la carestía de la vida. Euronews)
Amigos, amigas, justo cuando parecía que Portugal
estaba empezando a superar todos sus grandes
problemas, este 2023 ha supuesto otro jarro
de agua fría sobre este pequeño país europeo.
Y por eso en VisualPolitik nos hemos hecho
unas cuantas preguntas, ¿cómo se convirtió
Portugal en una promesa económica? ¿Cuál fue el
precio que tuvo que pagar para ello? ¿Por qué
las protestas están, otra vez, tomando las calles
del país? Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas,
pero antes vamos a ver un poco de historia.
T1(HACIA EL ABISMO)
Muchos, si no todos, ya sabéis que cuando
terminó la Segunda Guerra Mundial, el fascismo
no desapareció de Europa. No al menos del todo.
Y si, lo imagino, la gran mayoría estaréis
pensando en Francisco Franco, el dictador
español que estuvo 36 años en el poder.
Sin embargo, ¿sabíais que pese a eso casi
40 años, esta no fue la dictadura más
larga de Europa Occidental? Para encontrarla
tenemos que prestar atención, precisamente,
a nuestro protagonista de hoy: a Portugal.
(La dictadura portuguesa que dio comienzo
en 1926 se convirtió en la más longeva de
toda Europa occidental. Su principal figura,
António de Oliveira Salazar, un economista
que comenzó siendo ministro de finanzas del
dictador Óscar de Fragoso Carmona, se convirtió
en el primer ministro de la dictadura en 1932.
Su proyecto del “Estado Novo”, o Estado Nuevo,
priorizó el orden por encima de la economía,
lo que supuso mucha censura y, también,
la encarcelación de muchísimos activistas
y opositores políticos. Pese a ello, al menos
consiguió mantener a flote la economía del país,
lo hizo, eso sí, asumiendo tasas de desarrollo
mucho peores que las del resto de Europa.)
En cualquier caso, tras quedar incapacitado
después de sufrir una embolia en 1968,
la dictadura conocería sus últimos
años con el sucesor de Salazar,
Marcello Caetano, al que le tocó lidiar
con los movimientos nacionalistas en las
colonias portuguesas de África y,
también, con la crisis de 1973.
Al final, tras 48 años, la dictadura cayó
tras el alzamiento de oficiales del propio
Ejército en abril de 1974. Este movimiento pasó
a conocerse como la Revolución de los Claveles.
A partir de ese momento, Portugal se
sumergió en un turbio camino repleto
de cortas presidencias hasta 1986, cuando junto a
España ingreso en la Comunidad Económica Europea.
Ese fue un punto de inflexión. Durante
los siguientes 20 años la economía lusa
creció a un ritmo de prácticamente un
3% anual. No era para tirar cohetes,
pero supuso un cambio de 180 grados. Portugal
experimentó, al igual que países como España,
una enorme espiral de riqueza y modernización.
Sin embargo, en 2008 se desató la tragedia.
N2(1 de diciembre de 2008: Ya es oficial:
Recesión desde diciembre de 2007. CNN)
14 de noviembre de 2008: La Eurozona entra en
recesión por primera vez en la historia. El Mundo)
En nuestro canal hermano, VisualEconomik,
ya os hemos hablado del origen de esta crisis, de
cómo las hipotecas ninjas, la burbuja inmobiliaria
provocada por la expansión monetaria y el
estallido de esta, barrió el sistema financiero y
se llevó por delante a bancos como Lehman Brother.
Y aún peor, en 2008, la economía portuguesa no
solo vio cómo estallaba su particular burbuja
inmobiliaria y su economía empezaba a caer,
sino que en pocos años se desataría también
una enorme crisis de la deuda pública. El
estado portugués, ya de por sí bastante más
endeudado que la media de la Unión Europa, tuvo
que asumir de repente enormes cantidades de deuda.
En 2012, apenas 4 años después de estallar la
crisis, la deuda pública ya
superaba el 120% del PIB.
Cómo veis el problema fue bastante similar
al que se produjo en la mayor parte de
los países del sur de Europa.
La crisis fue mucho mayor de lo
que nadie esperaba. El gobierno portugués
respondió intentando alimentar la demanda
con más gasto público -una especie de
receta hipercalórica donde en vez de
calorías sumas deudas, intereses y más deudas.
Sin embargo, esta dieta fue completamente inútil.
Al final al primer ministro, José Sócrates, no le
quedó más remedio que meter la tijera, porque las
arcas públicas se quedaron completamente vacías.
En cierta forma el país se estaba deshaciendo.
Y en esas llegó al poder la figura clave de la
recuperación portuguesa: Pedro Passos Coelho.
(Passos Coelho, el entonces líder del conservador
PSD, ganó las elecciones anticipadas de 2011 con
un amplio margen. El pueblo luso lo escogió para
llevar a cabo una misión: recuperar Portugal.
Para hacerlo, el nuevo gobierno tuvo que tomar
una difícil decisión, la misma que también se
vieron obligados a tomar Grecia e Irlanda:
aceptar el rescate de la Comisión Europea
y el Fondo Monetario Internacional.
En concreto, Portugal recibió 78.000
millones de euros, eso sí, lo hizo con una
condición: abrazar la austeridad económica.
Coelho comenzó entonces en los momentos más
oscuros de la crisis, entre 2012 y 2013,
a tomar las decisiones más duras Por ejemplo,
recortó el gasto público en educación, sanidad
y asuntos económicos un 7%, redujo drásticamente
la protección al despido en un momento en que
el desempleo batía todos sus récords con niveles
de más 15%; y congeló tanto el salario mínimo en
500 euros, como el salario de los funcionarios.)
La pregunta es, ¿fue un proceso tranquilo? Para
nada. Como os podéis imaginar ante
semejante panorama ocurrió lo que
siempre suele ocurrir en estos casos: las
protestas comenzaron a inundar las calles.
Pese a todo, en 2014, después de 3 largos
años de un enorme sufrimiento económico,
el país comenzó a ver la luz. No era, en
cualquier caso, un punto de partida nada fácil.
N4(16 de mayo de 2014: Portugal
sale del rescate más empobrecida
y todavía lejos de la recuperación. Reuters)
Pero, ¿sabéis qué? A partir de entonces a Portugal
no solo le preocupó recuperarse por completo,
también quiso blindarse ante futuras crisis.
¿De qué estamos hablando? Pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T2(SACANDO MÚSCULO)
Después de tocar fondo,
la economía portuguesa comenzó a crecer de
nuevo, lo hizo a un ritmo más pausado, del
2,3% de media entre 2014 y 2019, pero, aun así, el
desempleo logró descender hasta poco más del 6%.
De esta forma, aunque Passos Coelho
no logró revalidar su mandar,
su gobierno logró encauzar la situación económica
y preparar los cimientos de la recuperación - de
la que por cierto luego saca pecho el actual
primer ministro, el socialista Antonio Costa,
pero bueno, ya sabéis, nada nuevo bajo el sol.
El caso es que el gobierno de Coelho no solo
redujo el gasto social, sino que también
planes como el programa SIMPLEX para
reducir la burocracia de la administración
pública. Esta medida fue clave, por ejemplo,
para recuperar la IED. Fijaos.
También se logró empezar a reducir
la deuda pública, que entre 2014
y 2019 cayó del 133(%) al 116%.
Ojo, aquí no estamos hablando de ningún milagro.
Como veis, el golpe de la crisis fue muy dura,
y los datos de la post-crisis tampoco son para
tirar cohetes. Pero, ¿qué queréis qué os diga?
Últimamente, ver que se reduzca la deuda pública
en estos países del sur de Europa es como ver,
no sé, al PSG ganar una competición europea.
Casi nunca ocurre, pero cuando lo hace… Es
que te dan ganas hasta de llorar de emoción.
Así que digamos que aquí el logro es que el
gobierno portugués logró estabilizar las cosas.
N5(29 de noviembre de 2018: Portugal devuelve al
FMI todos los créditos del rescate financiero de
2011. El organismo internacional le prestó más de
26.000 millones al 5.8% de interés. El País)
Estabilizar las cosas… Y también mejorar los
propios cimientos económicos
del país. Y ojo que esto ha
sido algo clave. ¿Por qué? Pues porque
en 2020 llegó la pandemia… Y esta vez,
esta vez Portugal no estuvo entre los
rezagados sino entre los aventajados.
(En 2020 su economía cayó más de un 8%, pero
en los dos años siguientes creció en un 5 y
un 6% respectivamente. Y no solo eso, el
país logró que pese a todos los esfuerzos,
la deuda pública se redujera hasta el 113%
en 2022. Es decir, en 2022 el ratio de deuda
pública de Portugal era inferior al de 2019. Y
eso, eso no ha sido nada pero que nada común.)
Amigos, para muchos analistas, Portugal se ha
convertido en una especie de ejemplo. Al menos
un ejemplo realista, asequible, imitable.
A base de incentivos fiscales, mejoras
regulatorias y una captación activa de la
inversión extranjera, hoy el desempleo es
relativamente bajo, la economía crece
y sus parámetros macro están mejorando.
Claro… que desgraciadamente
esta no es toda la historia.
T3(TURISMO E INVERSIÓN IGUAL A… ¿CRISIS?)
¿Recordáis que os hemos dicho que Coelho
redujo la burocracia para que Portugal
recibiera más inversión extranjera?
Bien, pues, como os podéis imaginar, esta no
fue la única medida que tomó para conseguir
encandilar a los inversores extranjeros.
Coelho se dio cuenta de que podía conseguir un 2
por 1 si jugaba bien sus cartas: no solo tenía la
oportunidad de atraer más inversión, sino también
de luchar contra uno de los mayores retos del
país, el creciente envejecimiento demográfico. Sí,
Portugal también es uno de esos países que
tienen por delante décadas muy complicadas.
La población mayor de 60 años supone ya casi el
30% de la población, u porcentaje que no dejará
de crecer intensamente durante los próximos años.
Pues bien, el caso es que Passos Coelho introdujo
dos polémicas medidas que pretendían atraer
inversión a la par que reducir la presión
demográfica. Coelho introdujo las famosas
“visas oro” y las “visas start-up”. Fijaos.
(Introducidas en 2012, las “visas oro”
otorgaban la residencia a extranjeros a
cambio de una inversión de 500.000 euros. En sus
primeros 7 años lograron recaudar más de 3.400
millones de euros gracias a la llegada de miles de
inversores con rentas estratosféricas desde China,
Rusia, Estados Unidos y varios países árabes que
querían disfrutar de una residencia e incluso
de la posibilidad de conseguir una
nacionalidad europea, al tiempo que
gozaban de las importantes desgravaciones
fiscales que este plan les otorgaba.
Por su lado, la “visa “start-up” fue impulsada
para atraer a fundadores de compañías que pudieran
presentar proyectos con el potencial de alcanzar
un valor de 325.000 euros o un volumen de negocios
anual superior a los 500.000 euros en 3 años.
Aunque no otorgara la posibilidad de acceder a
la nacionalidad portuguesa, esta sí contaba con
los beneficios fiscales que también aplicaban a
las “visas oro”, razón por la que la creación de
start-ups en el país se disparó, hasta liderar
la mejora emprendedora en toda Europa.)
Amigos, que estas visas lograron contribuir
a disparar la inversión extranjera
es algo innegable. Sin embargo,
no es oro todo lo que reluce. Estos visados
no solo llevaron dinero extranjero a Portugal,
sino que también contribuyeron a alimentar
una nueva crisis: la crisis de la vivienda.
Veréis, al compás de la recuperación económica,
la política monetaria de tipos cero y también las
visas internaciones, el precio de la vivienda en
Portugal se ha disparado. Por ejemplo, en Lisboa,
la capital, el alquiler medio de un piso
ya ronda los 2.000 euros. Esto por sí solo
no debería resultar un problema. Pero aquí viene
lo problemático: ¿recordáis que al principio del
video veíamos como Portugal estaba casi el último
en renta per cápita en Europa Occidental? Pues sí,
Portugal tiene un PIB per cápita de alrededor de
24.000 euros, y un salario mínimo de 760 euros.
Ahora, ¿creéis que con esas rentas pueden
permitirse un alquiler de 2.000 euros en
Lisboa? La verdad es que parece difícil.
C1(“A menudo, (los beneficiarios de
programas libres de impuestos, como
las visas doradas) remodelan una casa,
pero no la ocupan. Muchas veces esas
propiedades se venden una y otra vez,
y eso crea distorsión en el mercado
inmobiliario y es una de las causas
de la crisis de la vivienda” – Luís Mendes,
geógrafo e investigador de vivienda en una
entrevista a BBC Mundo, 30 de mayo de 2023.)
Por supuesto, la falta de vivienda tiene
más que ver con la regulación del suelo y la
construcción que con las visas… Pero este modelo
ha contribuido a que su precio se dispare.
Y no ha sido el único ingrediente que ha
contribuido a empeorar la situación. El
turismo también ha tenido mucho que ver.
En ciudades como Oporto, las casas diseñadas
para visitantes temporales, es decir, los pisos
turísticos, ya suponen 4 de cada 10 casas en
la ciudad, y los locales, los portugueses,
están teniendo cada vez más problemas para
encontrar pisos asequibles donde residir.
Evidentemente en países donde la
oferta es limitada… Si la demanda
crece, los precios se disparan.
Y eso explica noticias como estas:
N6(1 de abril de 2023: Miles de
personas protestan en Portugal por
crisis de la vivienda.VozdeAmerica)
¿Y qué ha ocurrido? Pues que el
gobierno del socialista Antonio
Costa ha comenzado a tomar medidas.
Por ejemplo: ha establecido un tope del
2% a los aumentos de precio recogidos
en los nuevos contratos de alquiler,
e incluso ha hecho que se apruebe la
obligación de alquilar las viviendas
privadas que estén vacías. Fijaos,
esto es lo que decía el proyecto de ley inicial
presentado por el partido socialista de Portugal:
C2(“Los propietarios de viviendas tendrán un plazo
de 100 días desde la recepción de una propuesta
de alquiler de las autoridades municipales
para volver a alquilar un inmueble vacío "en
condiciones de habitabilidad", Proyecto de ley de
vivienda presentado al público en marzo de 2023)
Conforme a este proyecto, los propietarios de
viviendas tendrían la obligación de comunicar
a las autoridades locales si un inmueble
se queda vacío. Entonces, las corporaciones
podrían hacer propuestas de alquiler. Y si el
proceso se extiendiera más de 100 días y la
vivienda siguiera vacía, los consistorios podrían
alquilarla forzosamente al precio que ellos mismos
hayan establecido para luego subarrendárselas a
otras personas en calidad de vivienda pública.
Al final, esta medida quedó más diluida. En la ley
aprobada por el parlamento esta medida se aplica
a los inmuebles que lleven más de dos años vacíos
y que estén situados en zonas costeras. Aun así,
sienta un claro precedente… Que ya os adelanto
que a los inversores no les gustará un pelo.
Y eso no es todo. La nueva regulación de
vivienda también ha establecido duros límites
a los pisos turísticos, incluyendo un nuevo
impuesto extraordinario del 15%, y, como no,
también se ha cargado el programa de “visas oro”.
Hablamos, por tanto, de uno de los
planteamientos de política de vivienda más
radicales que se han visto en toda Europa. Y
eso es precisamente lo que explica esta noticia:
N7(21 agosto 2023: Presidente de la República
veta programa Más Vivienda. Diario de Noticias)
Claro que, el veto presidencial no es definitivo.
La ley volvió al Parlamento y este la aprobó y la
reforma entro en vigor a comienzos de octubre. Sin
embargo, muchos portugueses son escépticos
de que este plan se llegue a consolidar,
¿por qué? Pues por una simple razón: Portugal
está sumido en una profunda crisis política.
Desde que Costa revalidó su puesto como primer
ministro en las elecciones parlamentarias de
2022 con mayoría absoluta después de ser incapaz
de aprobar los presupuestos generales en 2022,
ha tenido que hacer frente a 12 renuncias de altos
cargos de su gobierno por diferentes escándalos,
lo que le ha valido 2 mociones de censura
por parte del bloque de la derecha.
Por ejemplo: Carla Alves, ya ex secretaria de
Estado de agricultura, dimitió un día después
de asumir cuando la prensa dio a conocer
el embargo de las cuentas bancarias que
tenía con su marido, acusado de corrupción y
prevaricación. A esto también se le añade un
enfrentamiento abierto con el presidente
de la República, Marcelo Rebelo de Sousa.
Y por si fuera poco, hace poco nos encontramos
con la sorprendente noticia que comentábamos
al principio del vídeo.
N9 (Antonio Costa,
primer ministro de Portugal,
dimite al ser investigado en
un caso de corrupción. El Mundo)
Así que casi, casi que volvemos
al puto de partido. Portugal ha mejorado algunas
cosas, pero cuando parecía apostar por un modelo
de atracción de empresas, de repente ha dado
un nuevo volantazo en dirección contraria.
Es lo que tienen los países latinos, suelen
arreglar arañazos a base de más cañonazos.
En cualquier caso, esta es la historia de cómo
Portugal logró convertirse en una de las últimas
promesas europeas. La pregunta es, ¿logrará
seguir siéndolo? ¿Logrará Portugal combatir
la crisis de la vivienda sin arruinar la
economía nacional? ¿Qué haríais vosotros?
Dejadnos vuestras impresiones en los
comentarios y abramos debate. Y ahora,
si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante, no olvidéis darle a
like y suscribiros a VisualPolitik
si es que aún no lo habéis hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.